IIIi did I did a production in London in
the West End some 20 or more years ago
of Carmen Jones and it was a it was a it
is the most extraordinary show and we
had a wonderful wonderful cast and we we
introduce some extra dance elements into
the piece but of course the great big
number is beat out that rhythm on a drum
and I had a choreography I've often
worked with an Englishman young
Englishman who did a marvelous job and
everybody liked it very much but we all
felt that somehow he hadn't too immersed
himself enough in the darts culture out
of which the life depicted in common
Jones comes and the traditions
traditional dance forms that you might
find in New Orleans and so on and so we
found a choreographer who was a very
very distinguished dancer called William
Luthor who had danced with Martha Graham
a very distinguished choreographer had
worked all over Europe and so on and
William it was pretty well at the end of
his career and he said this is all wrong
what you're doing is is not it's nothing
authentic about it at all and he said
I'll show you he was old and in some
pain I think but he said I will show you
what I believe this dance should be and
to me was a perfect example of eccentric
dances I'd ever seen but it was a sort
of a mating dance and it was quite
extraordinary I won't attempt to
demonstrate that but it went in in no
direction that you would ever have
thought and it was as if he was dancing
a flamingo with certain backdrops and
weird little lingas Ford and so on it
was I'd never seen anything like it and
I must say he convinced us all that it
was the sexiest thing on and the dancers
as they learned to agree to break all
the rules that they had ever moved
according to what were gave performances
that surprised them and surprised all of
us and it was a fabulous thing to be in
touch with something as authentic as
that it was astounding so what my last
little comment about eccentric dance as
insofar as it concerns me or it's up to
well there there's of course forwarded
in the funeral which is not so much
eccentric as incompetent I think but
it's not surprising that Gareth died it
seems to me I've always thought of the
film as a sort of government health
warning against the perils of Scottish
dancing but well no as much younger I
lived in Africa as a boy from 1959 to
1962 and when I came back to England I
was a bit late starting school I was 12
or something that school started at 11
and there was a natural instinct to
bully the small fat boy who'd arrived
from abroad and nobody knew and I don't
know what it was in me that had a sort
of inspiration as they came towards me
flexing their fists I fell on the floor
and started jiggling around
and they they didn't know what to do
which part of me could you hit and I
said what's that what is that and I said
it's a jelly dance
it's an African jelly dance it's a
well-known traditional dance in Africa
and I'm its greatest living exponent and
it's because of that jelly dance ladies
and gentlemen I'm here in front of you
today